the city of Dunedin Florida wants to
take this man's home because I was tardy
cutting the grass Jim Dickens mom died
so he went to South Carolina to take
care of her estate
city officials then started finding
thicken $500 a day because his grass had
grown longer than 10 inches such fines
that up this is a letter from the city
attorney demanding twenty four thousand
four hundred fifty four dollars now the
fines up to $30,000 thickens neighbor
can't believe he was fined so much
because ficken doesn't have thirty
thousand the city says it will foreclose
on his home to collect the fine I was
shocked
the town says you're kind of a public
nuisance
I got everything fixed and took it and
taken care of it you only get it fixed
after they send warning after warning
the neighbors complain I guess I'm kind
of a slob why don't you just pay the
fine
thirty thousand dollars do you have
thirty thousand dollars lying around in
every instance that the city asked him
to do something Jim did it
lawyer Ari bargains defending fit gun
against the Nina the city has gone
nuclear
five hundred dollars per day for the
violation of having tall grass and now
he's facing the loss of his home
donita's politicians wouldn't talk to us
instead they paid $25,000 to this public
relations firm to speak to the media
there's the new PR manager costing
taxpayers twenty five thousand dollars
for just one month the PR firm says
Dunedin has no desire to impose large
fines their goal is just to ensure that
Dunedin is a high quality community but
if the politicians only cared about the
quality of the law they could have done
with their own ordinances permit them to
do which is hire a lawn service to come
out and mow the grass and send Jim a
bill for a hundred and fifty bucks but
they didn't do that they could do that
they absolutely can do that but they
didn't do that and that's because they
prioritize a revenue collection they
want the money it's pretty apparent that
code enforcement is a major cash cow for
the city of Dunedin 11 years ago Dunedin
collected 34
thousand dollars in fines last year 1.3
million
I got violated for a lawnmower in my
yard they violate me for a whole besides
a quarter in my stucco they find people
that they can pick on and then they keep
picking on them don't even put a lien on
her house
they say she owes them $32,000 sleepless
nights ahead because of this video did
they just try to think of what to say to
them just like you have to leave me
alone the city is just a bunch of
bullies and they expect people not to
stand up to him because to stand up to
it requires expensive legal help fake
and managed to get that legal help for
free from the Institute for justice a
law firm that defends individuals abuse
by government its lawyers portraying
themselves in this video as Western
heroes ready to punish bad guys say many
cities now pad their budgets by imposing
excessive fine the North Carolina City
find a local church $100 a branch for
excessive tree pruning private citizens
are being essentially extorted by their
governments and find incredible amounts
of money for really really small
violation if you can't pay the fine
they'll take your home the city of
Dunedin code enforcement would authorize
the City Attorney's Office to file
foreclosure actions the City Attorney of
Dunedin in the last year has sought
permission to foreclose on 18 properties
that violates the Eighth Amendment says
the institute for justice it not only
protects us from cruel and unusual
punishment but right next to that in the
Eighth Amendment is a protection to be
free from excessive fines our founders
they recognize that the ability to fine
is the ability to [ __ ] and it's one
of the ways other than incarceration
that government can really oppress if
governments can they will so we should
be grateful for the eighth amendment it
protects us from excessive fines and
what's more excessive than politicians
taking your home because you didn't cut
your grass
you